alors on va parler des des autres stars
et on va parler encore de vous bien sûr
catherine dos des autres stars qui ont
parlé publiquement de leur maladie
rappelez-vous jean luc delarue avait
révélé qu'il était atteint d'un cancer
de l'estomac et lui avait choisi de le
faire lors d'une conférence de presse
c'était en 2000 bouche je crois regarde
je suis entré le 15 au 16 novembre
dernier à l'hôpital
j'avais très mal au ventre on m'a retiré
4 litres d'eau dans le ventre et j'ai
compris très vite puisque les médecins
ont été parfaits et les infirmières
aussi que que j'avais un cancer
je me suis dit que tout bon de allez
savoir donc autant que ce soit moi qui
le disent on m'a dit qu'il était
important d'être entouré et je vois
plein de visages que j'aime beaucoup
aussi
et ça me touche et je dis un truc c'est
que y'a plus une minute à perdre et
qu'on ne vit que deux fois
merci voilà ça c'était jean luc delarue
il ya eu aussi jean pierre pernaut
présentateur du jt de 13 heures voilà de
tf1 depuis 1988 qui a annoncé sur son
facebook qui s'absentent et de l'antenne
suite à une opération d'un cancer de la
prostate
il a ensuite donné des nouvelles à ses
téléspectateurs à la suite de
l'opération il ya patrick poivre d'arvor
alors patrick poivre d'arvor ancien
présentateur phare du jt de tf1 s'était
confiée sur sa leucémie dont il était
atteint à 12 ans il a écrit un livre à
ce sujet qui s'appelle les enfants de
l'aube regarder qui m'est arrivé un
premier gros pépin on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure je les coucher
sur le papier à travers un roman
ça s'appelait les enfants de l'aube
j'avais 17 ans vous évoquez le jeune
frère d'antoine de saint-exupéry
françois qui a fermé les yeux à 15 ans
un âge dites vous dans la préface vous
auriez pu vous même basculer de l'autre
côté
j'avais eu en effet une maladie assez
grave une forme de leucémie et j'ai vu
beaucoup de mes camarades de l'époque
partie martyrs et donc pour moi c'était
important parce que cette photo que
saint-ex prend de son frère frère qui
s'appelle françois ça m'a bouleversé
pendant extrêmement longtemps
alors voilà ces stars donc qui parlent
de leur maladie dans les médias est ce
que vous êtes pour wii christine kelly
réagissent et bien sûr chez vous on est
en direct il est 23h 7
oui oui absolument et je soutiens
parfaitement catherine et toutes les
personnalités
moi aussi j'ai beaucoup croisé catherine
et quand j'étais lci et son sourire
permanent on le gardera à vie
ton sourire ta gentillesse lorsque
j'étais mama 3 heures du matin ça je
tiens quand même un tollé témoignait tu
as toujours été extraordinaire d'une
sensibilité même un croisement du matin
et je suis mère des trois heures du
matin
non mais c'est vrai était plein de
boîtes de nuit quand même nous croiser
nous disait franchement c'est très
important à dire parce que les gens ne
sont pas toujours les mêmes hors antenne
ll est extraordinaire et ce qui est bien
c'est que premièrement ces personnalités
savent qu'elles appartiennent au public
oui donc quand on appartient au public
ont eu droit aussi de lui dire des
choses deuxièmement il vaut mieux aussi
soi même dire les choses originales
comme le laissait apprendre qu'on est
mort par inadvertance parfait news comme
on l'apprend souvent ou bien mais de
maîtriser sa communication
quatrièmement c'est très important de se
soulager
mais aussi de soulager les autres et je
trouve que dans son livre et comme dans
toutes les personnes qui ont parlé elle
se soulage en parlant et c'est toujours
après un moment de réflexion et combien
de personnes ça soulage de lire qu'elle
a osé se remettre à nu pour témoigner et
bravo encore pont ce livre je peux me
permettre de lire un extrait en leur nom
à vous en lire un tout à l'heure je vais
avoir la vie à karim zéribi qui qui
entre les deux oui
cyril parce que moi je sais pas répondre
à cette question par oui ou par non les
stars doivent-elles parler de leur
maladie dans les médias il n'ya aucune
obligation je pense que chacun doit
faire comme il le sent d'abord et avant
tout avant d'être une star quand on est
malade on est un malade de qui on a
envie de partager ou pas on a envie de
garder dans l'intimité
on a envie d'être dans la pudeur ou pas
et donc je trouve que ya pas deux
viread obligations concernant le livre
de catherine laborde
on sent bien que lorsqu'elle a écrit ce
livre c'est parce que d'abord il a
ressenti un besoin mais elle elle le dit
que c'est presque une forme de thérapie
de quai et en même temps effectivement
c'est tellement on fait avec le coeur
avec la sincérité et l'authenticité qui
la caractérise non c'est pas un talent
je la connaissais pas catherine laborde
mais je lui ai non plus vous connaissez
pas oui il n'y a plus de chance que moi
je la connais ce que l météo car ce
qu'elle nous a accompagné quand même
pendant des années tous ici et de quelle
que soit l'activité qui était la nôtre
et je lui dis donc dans les loges que je
l'aimé sans la connaître et serge les
mais avant qu'elle soit malade et
effectivement elle est encore plus
touchante à travers ce livre pourquoi
parce qu'elle me dégage un humanisme une
beauté naturelle elle ne se force pas
elle ne triche pas c'est une femme
enceinte qu'elle a de l'amour à donner
et elle dit des choses dans ce livre qui
sont très touchantes sur ce qu'elle
ressent sur ses douleurs sur son ancrage
sur les aidants et je crois que ce livre
peut être utile à ceux qui sont atteints
par la maladie aujourd'hui parce qu'il
ya une nécessité aujourd'hui de ne pas
se sentir seul
et si j'ai envie de dire c'est le
premier message qu'elle dit vous n'êtes
pas seuls alors catherine ont voulu
opposer un non je vous aime un quatrième
vous m4 intérêt qu'on vous aime
catherine je vous poser une dernière
question dans un instant avant l'avis de
bernard laporte
oui pour répondre à la question c'est
délicat ça dépend tellement du caractère
et de la personnalité
certains vont se cacher mais je veux
surtout pas qu'on sache et d'autres vont
effectivement dire dévoile à moi j'ai
une filiation terril avec mon public que
mon public doit tout savoir sur moi sur
mes la question déjà vie te poser 4e et
de c je suis comme comme karim on t'aime
et tu sais est-ce que c'est pas aussi
pour te pour aller chercher du soutien
pour lutter contre la maladie et se dire
beaucoup de gens vont m'accompagner
beaucoup de gens vont me soutenir tu
sais que tu es aimé par la france
entière et à travers cette déclaration
il ya des gens qui viennent vers toi qui
est peut-être que tu te sois encore plus
forte pour aller lutter contre cette
maladie
est ce que c est ce que tu vas pas aussi
rechercher sa ce que j'ai recherché
bernard cessez de m'adresser à ceux qui
qu'ils vont lire ce livre dit c'est pas
l'effet que ça pourrait avoir sur moi ou
pas assez c'est je m'adresse à quelqu'un
c'est important que ce que je le
visualiser que j'arrive est ce que tous
ces témoignages ça te donne pas encore
plus de force
ah ça c'est sûr bien sûr ça c'est sûr je
pense que quand on pose la question est
est-ce qu'il faut parler de la maladie
ou pas oui de quelle que manière que ce
soit parce que le regard de l'autre
l'attention de l'autre la l'amitié de
l'autre sont essentielles pour la il ya
une vertu très apaisante catherine dans
ce livre c'est que quand on a des
destins qui sortent un peu de
l'ordinaire
quand on fait de la télé du cinéma
l'écriture aux autres le fait que des
gens qui n'ont pas ce type de destins
puisse s'identifier en disant en fait
en dépit de ce qu'elle a fait de ce
qu'elle est de sa notoriété
en fait on a un point commun c'est qu'on
partage la même maladie et à ce moment
là c'est super important parce que les
gens qui sont concernés et qui n'ont pas
cette notoriété sentent que tu partages
avec eux quelque chose de très fort
alors agathe alia toujours avoir votre
avis oui est quelque chose de très
important a souligné selon moi c'est que
votre livre c'est un livre sur la
maladie bien sûr mais c'est aussi un
livre d'espoir sur le combat contre
cette maladie sur vivre avec cette
maladie c'est un véritable message
d'espoir que vous donnez et c'est pour
ça que moi je trouve votre démarche
effectivement thérapeutique et
salvatrice pour vous même mais pour tous
les lecteurs qui s'en sont atteints et
qui trouve dans ce livre un simple
message qui dit vous je suis avec vous
quoi on est exactement la même chose et
vous écrivez un passage absolument
incroyable c'est page 88 89 vous dites
je vis aujourd'hui avec une intensité
dont je ne me serais jamais cru capable
comme si je connaissais de la vie des
moments des sentiments que les bien
portants ne perçoivent pas une autre
approche de l'existence nous gagne j'ai
adoré ce passage il est frappé d'une
philosophie de la vie vous aimez la vie
catherine